c'est ici à montréal que l'oaci
réglemente la sécurité de l'aviation
civile internationale
mais sa propre sécurité informatique
était un vrai fromage plein de trous en
quand des pirates informatiques se sont
introduits dans ses serveurs ils ont pu
accéder aux données personnelles des
employés présents et passés mais aussi
de quiconque avait visité le bâtiment ou
le site web de l'oaci les documents
mentionnent que la taxe serait très
probablement l'oeuvre de cyber espions
chinois appelé et mystery band à ce
qu'on peut imaginer étant donné aussi
dans le groupe qu'on soupçonne sont les
rapports être derrière cette attaque que
l'objectif était plus un objectif
d'espionnage d'obtenir des données des
données confidentielles n'ont pas
nécessairement de l'oaci mais des
partenaires en aviation qui vont se
connecter sur les sites de l'oaci les
autorités d'aviation civile nationale
mais aussi à lies manufacturiers et les
fournisseurs de services les documents
denquête externe révèle que des membres
de l'équipe des technologies de
l'information de l'oci ont tardé à
réagir et fait preuve d' obstruction et
de négligence pour camoufler leur
mauvaise gestion
selon des sources confidentielles de
siby si la secrétaire générale pnue a
aussi écarté des recommandations pour
enquêter sur les membres de l'équipe et
leur patron james wan
tous travaillent encore à l'organisation
pendant ce temps le gouvernement fédéral
n'a pas été informé de cette
cyberattaque savait que l'oaci et
gan des nations unies ça ne relève pas
extraire la marche générale on est
membre par contre ça me préoccupe de
l'oaci affirme que l'importance de l'
affaire a été exagérée et que les
informations personnelles des canadiens
n'ont pas été mises à risque
l'organisation ajoute avoir fait de
solides améliorations à sa cyber
sécurité pour prévenir de tels incidents
on ne sait toujours pas quels sont les
organisations qui ont pu être infectés
puisque le fichier du serveur qui
contenaient ces informations a
mystérieusement disparu ici thomas
gerber radio canada montréal